et nous sommes avec monique dental
présidente du réseau féministe ruptures
et nicolas glières enseignants et
membres des stylos le rouge bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir nicolas
glières l'encré de l'écriture inclusive
et ce qu'elle était réellement enseigner
aux élèves qu'est ce qu'elle change
cette interdiction officielle est ce que
vous êtes un peu favorable bonsoir à
toutes les deux alors non elle n'est pas
particulièrement enseigne elle n'est pas
particulièrement présente dans les
manuels ou autre la première chose que
je tenais à dire c'est que c'est un faux
débat dans le sens où monsieur blanc
caire instrumentalise utilise comme il
aime le faire accroire que c'est son
seul travail des questions sociétales
des questions sociales avant tout pour
diviser la gauche qui n'a pas besoin de
lui pour ça ou pas sache
mais bon ça c'est autre chose je pense
qu'on sera d'accord là-dessus clairement
il instrumentalise une question pour
faire du buzz pour diviser pour ne pas
montrer qu'il n'a rien fait pour le
reste le dis parce qu'elle est renseigné
par certains de vos collègues
oui possiblement mais c'est très
marginal
vraiment c'est très marginal si c'est le
cas et je vous réponds alors là je vous
réponds vraiment avec une franchise
totale
je pense que quelques-uns le fond mais
la plupart nous ce n'est pas présent
dans les manuels je tiens à le dire
surtout ce n'est pas vraiment la
question importante
il me semble quand même qu'il ya des
choses beaucoup plus importantes
on est un métier avec 70 % de femmes on
sait que les femmes sont moins payées
que les hommes
la première revendication des stylos
rouges ce sont les salaires déjà ça sera
un gros jet ce fait notamment vers les
fables envers les profs en général si
monsieur blon caire nous augmentait il a
préféré rendre de l'argent au ministère
des finances à monsieur le maire pour
faire le sale boulot libéral anglais et
pendant ce temps là on est toujours
précarisés mal payés et notamment les
femmes dans le métier donc plus que
l'écriture inclusive
il ferait mieux de toute façon de
s'occuper de nos salaires des moyens du
nombre d'élèves dans les classes et
d'empêcher les inspecteurs et les chefs
d'établissement nous harceler déjà
l'école iraient beaucoup beaucoup mieux
avec cela à l'écriture inclusif c'est
superficiel c'est pas un espace pas
l'histoire
alors on va vous faire réagir à monique
et ton talent c'est superficiel
l'écriture inclusive en quoi est-ce que
ça participe d'une égalité
hommes femmes et d'un changement des
mentalités oui je pense que j'aurais pas
tout à fait le même point de vue parce
qu'il me semble que tout est important
en réalité que ce soit la question des
salaires que ce soit la question de
l'écriture inclusif et et en quoi d'une
certaine manière c'est important de
féminiser à la fois les titres les
fonctions mais là on sait que monsieur
blanc calme est revenu là dessus mais en
quoi c'est important aussi les clôtures
abusive qu'il ne faut pas trop limité
parce qu'il ya plusieurs conceptions de
les cultures inclusive en elle-même
l'exigence bahr également en visite
concernant le point médias vous semble
aller dans le bon sens pour davantage
d'égalité homme femme
non mais je voudrais quand même terminé
sur la phrase que j'avais commencé qui
était que je pense que c'est important
parce que le rôle quand même deux des
enseignants c'est de forger l'esprit de
l'enfant qui malgré tout va devenir un
futur adulte et que qui force son
imaginaire et sont symboliques et la
question de l'écriture à une certaine
importante parce que quand on enseigne à
un enfant que le masculin l'emporté sur
le féminin d'emblée l'enfant il pense
que les filles c'est pas important que
les filles c'est inférieur et que les
garçons c'est normal qu'ils dominent les
filles c'est en tout cas souvent comme
ça que ça se passe dans les familles
quand les petits garçons reviennent à la
maison
donc je pense que cette question n'est
pas anodine et que tout a son importance
je suis d'accord avec la question des
salaires avec le fait qu'il faut
l'égalité des salaires etc
et puis bon pour l'autre partie de la
question que vous me posez évidemment
personnellement par exemple dans notre
association n'utilisant pas
obligatoirement le point pour
différentes raisons parce que nous
pensons que le point le désavantage
c'est que il ponctue une normalement une
phrase et que donc c'est difficile pour
un enfant et pour un esprit d'enfant de
comprendre que quentin une phrase est
ponctuée par un point un mot est aussi
ponctuée par un point et de rajouter le
féminin voilà donc il ya d'autres
possibilités et nous on est beaucoup
plus
en accord avec ce qu'on appelle le
pluriel de proximité qui d'ailleurs est
utilisée au canada et dans d'autres pays
et qui était utilisé en france
d'ailleurs dans les siècles passés et et
que bon le système patriarcal a
complètement aboli à partir du moment où
effectivement on a figé le fait que les
femmes étaient dépendantes des hommes
donc la langue est venu ajouter cette
conception qui est une conception
patriarcale et est très masculine is
quite macheist donc je crois que trouver
une solution qui n'est pas
obligatoirement le point moi je ne suis
pas gêné par sa est inné qui peut-être
le tirait déjà il est une autre façon de
faire de l'écouteur inclusive mais il ya
aussi d'autres possibilités 1
par exemple le pluriel de proximité qui
est utilisée au canada et en norvège et
dans d'autres pays
et bien c'est par exemple le fait de
considérer que le mot qui précède le
pluriel est le plus important pour
déterminer justement l'orthographe du
pluriel c'est à dire vous pouvez m nous
sommes fâchés par exemple fâché et bien
si c'est les garçons qui sont fâchés cs6
et les filles qui sont fâchés c et e s
c'est à dire que il ya d'autres types de
possibilités pour faire de la culture un
fusil qui ne jeu suffirait pas
effectivement qu'on reste sur l'idée que
le masculin l'emporté sur le féminin ce
qui est quand même date à ce trafic des
deux points de vue là on ne peut pas
être d'accord évidemment en tant que
féministe avec les propos de monsieur
blanc coeur qui lui a quand même dit
qu'il fallait conserver cette règle et
ça c'est un vrai problème
nicolas glières comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à ses propos comment est ce
que on apprend à l'école à des
tout-petits l'égalité hommes femmes est
ce qu effectivement l'écriture à tout
son rôle à jouer et concernant alors bon
on va pas rentrer dans les détails dans
les différentes façons de mettre en
forme l'écriture inclusive mais
concernant le point médian qui vient
d'être proscrit par l'éducation
nationale
comment est ce qu'on apprend une telle
technique à des enfants qu'ils sont
parfois en difficulté avec les
apprentissages les plus simples et les
plus courants
le point mais enfin je suis en accord
avec beaucoup de choses qui vient d'être
dit notamment sur l'accord de proximité
qui avait cours au xviie siècle et qui a
été abolie par des matches on n'a pas
d'autre moore les machos qui ont fondé
l'académie française et et ça me paraît
tout à fait bon sens en revanche le
point médian
je vais être plus radical que vous
madame dental mais je suis d'accord avec
vous le point médian c'est une des psys
pour moi il n'ya il n'a aucun intérêt il
est très compliqué en plus il ne
correspond pas du tout à ce qu'on dit le
nombre doit quand même correspondent à
son oral et l'oral à l'écrit
alors évidemment quand on regarde
l'anglais avec le moonlight avec j'ai
acheté qu'on ne prononce pas je suis
d'accord que ça pose problème aussi mais
le point médian rajoute une difficulté
avec des enfants qui ont déjà du mal et
de plus en plus de mal ne nous cacherons
pas venu chez les silos rouge on se bat
aussi pour pour qu'on travaille plus la
grammaire l'orthographe par exemple
refaire acquérir ces no chi qui ont été
un peu perdue en pénis de côté pendant
des décennies donc ils ont déjà du mal à
décrire si en plus on leur met des
points eux pointent eux s ils sont
complètement perdus ils ont déjà du mal
à trouver le phénoménal pluriel en
revanche oui on a on apprend ce genre de
phrases idiotes quam le masculin le
remporte
elle est aberrant elle est idiote ne
peut pas dire le contraire
alors ça serait très compliqué à
expliquer mais historiquement c'est le
neutre qu'il remportait simplement ça ne
se voit pas parce qu'on l'attend je suis
aussi preuves de l'apport le masculin et
le neutre une partie du masculin du no 2
deuxième déclinaison de me frapper pas
sont quasiment identiques dans leur
déclinaison est en fait c'était ça la
règle
la règle c'était que ça donnait du
neutre mais le neutre a disparu vers le
13ème 14ème siècle en français voilà
pour le petit cours d'histoire de la
langue mais vraiment le point médian a à
titre personnel là je parle pas pour les
stylos rouges je ne vous cacherai pas
parce qu'on n'est pas tous d'accord pour
le coup mais je trouve que c'est une
ineptie et qu'on ne se bat pas pour les
droits des femmes
on rentre dans une langue l'aide
illisible incompréhensible
en revanche en revanche il ya d'autres
choses qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes
j'ai parlé des salaires tout à l'heure
je parle aussi de la coéducation des
enfants il faut que les pères sont
probablement plus des enfants et que les
maires laisse les pères s'occuper des
enfants
ça va dans les deux sens non on va
rester sur le débat concernant
l'écriture inclusive parce que si le
point médian est proscrit par ministère
de l'éducation en revanche
le ministère l'éducation préconise
l'usagé de la féminisation des métiers
et des fonctions un usage qui fait
partie aussi des pratiques constitutive
de lait cru tir inclusive vous saluer sa
monique dental dans l'imaginaire des
enfants quel impact est ce que ça peut
avoir une telle mesure
c est exactement comme la revendication
de la parité pour lequel nous nous
sommes battus pendant quand même que dix
ans chez les féministes
non mais de toute façon monsieur blanc
car il n'a pas à dire que c'est lui qui
a inventé la féminisation des titres et
des fonctions c'est yvette roudy qui a
fait passer un texte en 1984 alors je
veux dire par rapport à ça on réinvente
pas l'eau chaude
c'est à dire que l'as c'est nécessaire
d'utiliser ce texte qui existe sur
l'utilisation des titres et des
fonctions et c'est très important
d'avoir les titres des fonctions
féminisé parce que d'abord l'enjeu c'est
que les jeunes filles et les filles
arrivent à être dans tous les métiers et
à égalité avec les hommes c'est tout
donc féminisation des mots ça peut agir
justement sur un comportement son
comportement d'une petite fille pompiers
et pompières par exemple quelques revers
qui peut la pousser à formater vers se
doit bien sûr parce que ça veut dire que
tous les métiers sont ouverts que rien
n'est interdit pendant très longtemps
vous savez les femmes par exemple qu'ils
étaient des écrivaines comme on dirait
aujourd'hui est bien entendu elles ont
dû utiliser des noms d'hommes pour
pouvoir être publié donc ça veut dire
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup plus par
la suite
toutes les femmes qui ont dû
effectivement être dans des métiers où
elles n'étaient pas acceptées elles ont
dû soit d'abord passer par des hommes
qui pouvait les installer dans ses
métiers ou alors elles ont dû davantage
que beaucoup d'hommes travailler pour
arriver à prouver qu'elle était capable
donc il faut arrêter cette situation ou
pour pouvoir être accepté une fois en
faire dix fois plus il faut qu'une
petite fille qui grandit et qui veut
être
je veux dire chimiste ou être
cosmonautes elles puissent le faire sans
que l'on lui interdisent parce qu on lui
on lui dit quelque part que c'est pas
des métiers pour elle parce que plus
tard elle sera mariée elle fera des
enfants et ce sera
bien qu'elle s'occupe du foyer ce qui
est derrière c'est ça c'est à dire les
les structures sexuée de la société où
les femmes sont faites pour avoir des
enfants et les phillies hommes sont
faits pour faire la guerre ou peur de la
culture on en est vraiment encore là un
jeu dangereux
comment on en est vraiment encore là
aujourd'hui
ah oui dans dans certaines situations
les filles sont encore élevés comme ça
bien entendu et surtout aussi ce qui
arrive c'est que quand vous regardez par
exemple donc les orientations
malheureusement il ya encore beaucoup
trop d'orientation qui sont faites vers
des métiers entre guillemets dits
féminins et des métiers dits masculins
regarder les filles pourquoi on les
trouve beaucoup moins dans les classes
prépas pourquoi on les trouve moins en
sciences pourquoi on les trouve moi en
physique chimie
c'est pas hasard tout ça se joue un tout
dernier mot n'est que la glières et très
rapidement si vous le voulez bien je
suis navré le temps nous manque ou
qu'est ce que vous constatez vous dans
vos classes est ce que malgré tout il ya
une évolution est ce que les petites
filles se sentent tout à fait apte à
faire les mêmes métiers qui il ya encore
quelques années ne semble être destiné
qu'aux petits garçons il ya un effet là
dessus il ya plus de filles qui veulent
faire des métiers destiné à la base à
l'ancienne aux garçons mais les schémas
reste extrêmement encore marqué les
schémas sont très marqués beaucoup de
filles et beaucoup de gars on s'oriente
en fonction de leur sexe concrètement je
pense pas que ce soit vraiment
l'écriture qui changent massivement la
donne je rappelle quand même que ce sont
bien des écoles de filles qui sont
brûlés dans plein de petites écoles de
petit garçon et je pense pas que
l'écriture changera sa malheureusement
je pense pas que ce soit l'accès se
situe en fait ce sera lorsque ça reste
une question mineure par rapport à des
choses beaucoup plus importantes et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à cet échange ce
soir nicolas glières enseignants et
membres des stylos roches monique dental
présidente du réseau féministe ruptures